- [Narrator] Hello, everyone.
Let's talk about potential energy.
Potential energy is energy
that is stored in an object,
and this energy is related
to the potential or the future possibility
for an object to have a
different type of energy,
like kinetic energy for motion,
that is converted from
that potential energy.
There are many kinds of potential energy,
but they all arise from
an object's relation
to a position, or an original shape.
So while in general,
there are many different
types of potential energy,
there are several specific
types that are very common.
So, let's talk about these.
Gravitational potential energy
is the potential energy
that an object with mass has
due to the force of gravity
from another object with mass,
like say, the Earth.
And in fact, we often use
the surface of the Earth
to compare an object's position with
to see how much potential energy it has
in the Earth's gravitational field.
Gravity is an attractive force,
so objects with mass want to move
towards the surface of the Earth.
If we move them further away,
or opposite the direction
of the gravitational force,
we increase their
gravitational potential energy.
And the opposite is
true if it gets closer.
When an object is on the surface of Earth,
we typically say it has
no potential energy,
but you could use any
point to be this comparison
where potential energy is zero.
Consider a book on a bookshelf.
If the book is on this shelf,
we can use this shelf as
the 0.4 potential energy.
Moving it to a higher shelf
would mean it has
gravitational potential energy
relative to that lower shelf,
or relative to the floor
if we want to use that as
our comparison instead.
Next, we have elastic potential energy,
which is the potential energy
some objects have due to
their shape being changed.
These types of objects are
called elastic objects.
Elastic objects are made
of materials and designed,
so they have internal or inside forces
that try to return them
to their original shape.
One very common example
of this is a spring.
When you stretch or compress a
spring, you change its shape.
And the shape of the spring
causes internal forces
that try to return the
spring to its original shape.
Now electric potential energy,
which is the potential
energy a charged object has
due to the electric force
from another charged object.
Opposite electric charges
are attracted to one another,
and similar electric charges are repelled.
So the potential energy
depends on what type of charges there are,
and how far apart they are.
Potential energy increases
when the charges move
opposite the direction
of the electric force,
for example, when two negative
charges get closer together.
Similarly, magnetic potential energy
is the potential energy
a magnetic object has
due to the magnetic force
from another magnet.
Magnetic force causes similar
poles to repel one another,
and opposite poles to attract.
And because magnets have
north and south poles,
the potential energy depends not only
on the position within a field,
but also the magnets orientation.
Again, you could increase
the potential energy
by moving the magnets
opposite the direction
of the magnetic force.
For example, by pulling apart
a North Pole and a South Pole.
All of these types of energy
are due to different forces,
and are calculated differently
from different equations,
which we won't cover here,
but they are all potential energy.
And these are just a few
of the most common types
of potential energy, but there are more.
In summary, potential
energy is the stored energy
in an object due to its
position, its properties,
and the forces acting on it.
Potential energy is measured
relative to some comparison
position or shape,
and describes the potential
for other forms of energy,
commonly kinetic energy
for motion, to exist.
There are many forms of potential energy,
including gravitational,
elastic, magnetic, and electric.
Thanks for watching,
and I hope you learned a
little bit of something.